this is the outskirts of mikk alive in
southern ukraine the latest city to
experience a russian artillery
bombardment
they're hitting balabanovka hitting
residential homes shooting
horror
and desperation to share with the world
what is happening
let's show everyone
all the windows are blown off and the
doors as well
their situation becoming ever more
desperate ukraine's president zielenski
renewed his calls for tougher sanctions
against russia
if somebody loses their mind we have to
lose fear and forget about commerce we
need to defend ourselves both countries
and companies must take a moral stand
and fight against an inhumane force
which wants to destroy humanity itself
still dogged by criticism for not doing
more to punish russia and welcome
ukrainian refugees boris johnson
announced an additional 175 million
pounds of uk aid for ukraine
after 12 days it's already clear that
putin has made a miscalculation
he has underestimated the ukrainians
their heroic resistance he's
underestimated their leader
and he has underestimated the unity of
the west and we will continue as
colleagues to do everything we can to
strengthen that unity in the days ahead
to ensure that putin fails in this
catastrophic invasion of ukraine
there are explosions in the distance
during a day of supposed ceasefire
those too young to understand and too
old to help themselves are fleeing kiev
picking their way past this destroyed
overpass in earpin on the outskirts of
the capital it's a dangerous and
exhausting journey but what choice do
they have it's like a disaster the city
is almost ruined in the district where
i'm living it's
like no houses which were not bombed
this pin
falls off kiev's defenders are no longer
just ukrainians foreign fighters are
helping to prepare for a long-awaited
russian advance fighting for democracy
because
democracy is precious and one man can
decide that another country shouldn't
have it
ukrainian officials have arrived in
belarus for a third round of ceasefire
talks with russia
but vladimir putin has vowed he will
take ukraine via talks or war so hopes
for progress are slim
tom clark sky news